allez y lève toi
bonjour brel stephen tu as conscience
que tu t'embarques et de toi même dans
un doctorat en physique
salut salut étudiants en sciences mois
en lettres
si l'inversé le temps pour savoir ce qui
a pu se passer au commencement remonter
le temps
remontez le temps continue et j'ignore
comment pour l'instant continue de
remonter jusqu où
mais
ça s'appelle la sclérose latérale
amyotrophique
l'espérance de vie est de 2 ra nous
profitions ensemble du temps qui nous
reste
nous allons lutter ensemble contre cette
maladie
bonne chance
comment allez-vous plutôt bien des dons
cette histoire de trous noirs au début
du temps c'est brillant très brillant
stephen bravo d'acteur il a une homo ni
seule solution pour qu'il survive de
pratiquer une trachéotomie ne pourra
plus jamais parler mais s'il parlera je
m'appelle stephen hawking c'est pas très
naturel ça vous pose un problème j'ai eu
la joie incommensurable dans ma vie de
voir cet homme relever les défis les
plus invraisemblables tant sur le plan
scientifique que personnel
rien ne doit limiter l'activité humaine
leur vie n'est pas toujours belle tant
qu'il y a de la vie il ya de l'espoir